So have you all noticed that
everything kind of sucks now?
And I don't mean, like, the
general state of the world.
I mean, like, the stuff we buy
is just, like
a little bit worse than it was
10 years ago.
And I really started thinking about this
because my coworker Izzie wrote about
how she had to replace a bra.
So I'm gonna do what any normal person would do
which is buy the exact same thing from the exact same place.
And then after a few weeks
it just kind of...
Just kind of fell apart.
So this kind of started me
on this journey of
okay, I'm hearing anecdotally from
so many people I talk to
in my life.
From coffee machines...
phones, computers, sweaters...
They all tear or break
or explode way sooner
than they used to.
So what's going on?
And is there a way to climb out
from under this pile of consumer trash?
So let's talk about this in the most
basic of terms
starting with the design process.
When a company wants
to make a thing
let's say, like a jacket
there are three main factors to consider.
Functionality: Does it work?
Appearance: Does it look good?
And manufacturability:
Is it easy and fairly inexpensive
to make a lot of this product?
Generally, a good product will have a good blend
of these three things.
But in recent years
this process has been thrown off balance.
Let's look at clothes, for example.
In the past, if you needed
a new jacket
you used to go to a tailor,
get measured
choose material and
have it made.
Then for decades, instead of going
to a tailor for a jacket
we went to department stores
and bought things that were mass produced.
By the 80s and 90s
we had tons of options and stores to choose from.
And now many of us just kind of go online
click "add to cart" and
buy a product
without ever seeing it
in person.
But it's not just how we buy,
it's how often we buy.
And for that, we can kind of
blame this man.
Ernest Elmo, yeah,
incredible name.
In the 1930s, during the Great Depression
he wrote this paper
that was like
"Okay, the government
should really support
this idea of planned obsolescence."
Except he didn't call it planned obsolescence.
He called it "consumer engineering."
Remember that jacket you bought?
Well, it's a new season, and it's out of style.
Buttons are out.
Zippers are in.
So you buy something new.
But not because there was anything
physically wrong with the original.
That's why it's called consumer engineering, right?
Like, it's up here in the brain.
And we've been living this way
for decades.
So now we all want the next best thing, all the time.
And that demand has
spun out of control.
Today we are surrounded.
The speed of certain trend cycles and
the fact that they're geared
towards these micro communities.
Like Stanley cups, when maybe a year ago
was Hydro Flasks.
The result is that we buy a lot.
A survey done in 2021 found that nearly
40% of UK consumers
buy clothing as often as once a month.
The UN reports that between
the years 2000 and 2014
the average person was buying 60% more clothing...
and each item was only kept half as long.
So we want to buy a lot of stuff fast
and because we replace our stuff so often
we don't really want to spend a lot of money on it...
which has an effect too.
People aren't willing to pay more
for something they had purchased a while ago.
So like if I paid 30 bucks
for a bra, 10 years ago
it would be really hard for me to buy it at $50.
Even though in the last 10 years labor costs have risen.
So what we're left with
is an incredibly fast
cycle of demand for low cost products.
And here's what that looks like.
In order to speed up manufacturing
companies have to either hire more people
alter how the product is made
or both.
But they also have to keep prices
low enough for consumers to keep buying.
So they may start swapping materials
like cotton or silk for a cheaper synthetic material.
Or rely on a more basic stitching pattern
that maybe just doesn't hold as well.
So if after 10 years, you're still paying
the same price
or close to the same price for a product
that looks the same...
well, something had to change.
So you might say,
"okay, Kim, fashion trends are moving too fast
and we buy too much stuff. I get it. I get it."
"But why does my washing machine suck?"
And that's a great question.
Let's talk about technology.
When things like computers
first became part of our daily lives
it made a lot of sense to upgrade devices pretty often.
There was actually very big differences in what a device did
that's 2 years old versus one that
was brand new in the market.
There was just big leaps.
This is Gay Gordon-Bryne.
She directs a consumer advocacy group
called the Repair Association.
You know, if you had a 2 year old thing
you probably couldn't do
half the cool stuff
that the other guy could do.
So that kind of fueled
the replacement cycle because you really did
get something better in terms of functionality.
For example, when the iPhone was first made
it was a major breakthrough.
Subsequent phones up to a point
responded to major technological leaps.
Like look at the difference between
the 3GS and the 4.
The iPhone 4 had a way better resolution
and a front facing camera.
For a while, these major leaps
between models was the norm for technology.
But we're not making those giant changes as often anymore.
Instead, partly to make us want to buy more things...
companies make very minor adjustments year after year.
So the dryer you own may now play
a fun little song at the end of a cycle
instead of screaming.
And now, as devices advanced
and got increasing complicated
there was another problem
for consumers.
All these things started to come into the into the world.
They didn't come in
with repair tools.
They came in to be thrown away.
Basically, when this stuff breaks.
It's often intentionally impossible to repair.
Because if you buy something that has a computer chip in it
or a circuit board or whatever
you probably can't make one in your garage.
So you're very reliant on
what the manufacturer will agree to sell.
And very often they don't agree to sell parts
and tools and diagnostics or even give you a diagram.
But sometimes it really just isn't possible to fix
because they cut corners, just like in fashion
replacing metal and screws with
plastic and glue.
And these kind of issues apply
across the board in technology...
from your phone to toasters to blenders...
to electric wheelchairs to your car.
If you walk around your house or your apartment
and you start cataloging
how many things you own that have chips in them
I think you'll be really surprised how big that
lack of repair problem actually is.
I want people to feel hopeful.
Yes, this is something that's
out of our control in some ways
and not out of our control in others.
I don't want you to feel guilty for partaking in...
in this system where like so many people, we've been kind of
brought up culturally to think in this way
or to buy in this way.
Compared to other things that suck in the world
we actually have a
surprising amount of control
over this situation.
With tech, fighting for the right to repair
is actually extremely effective.
New York State just passed the right to repair bill in 2022
and it's not perfect but at least
it's something.
With fashion, stay away from
micro trends
and fast fashion as often as you can.
Buy with intention and learn to take care
of the things you do have.
Think of your objects as having maintenance.
Read those care labels.
As consumers, it's going to take a little bit for us
to sift through all that trash and retrain our brains a bit.
But we can take small steps
to take back control of the process.
After all, all of this stuff is supposed to be made for us.
So let's make it clear what we want.
We have a map on our
repair.org website
where you can go find your state...
click the picture...
and it'll bring up a—basically,
a letter writing widget.
Type in your address
and it says...
Tell your repair story.
And if you really want
to do something
that's how it gets done.
We've had over 100,000
people do that.
Over 30,000 of them
in New York.
So, it does not surprise me that
New York was the first one to
actually pass a law.
Because that's where there was
a really big groundswell of interest.